le thème de cette audition c'est
naturellement les systèmes d'information
liés au covid je voudrais d'ores et déjà
vous rappeler que madame la Présidente
de la CNIL sera auditionné également par
la mission d'information de la
commission des lois qui porte sur les
images de sécurité et qui aura lieu
mardi prochain le 18 à 15h c'est une
mission qui est rapportée par Philippe
Latour mais par Philippe Gosselin
sur les questions qui nous occupent
aujourd'hui la loi du 30 juillet 2022 a
mis fin à la plupart des mesures
exorbitantes du droit commun pour la
gestion de la crise sanitaire et la
prorogée jusqu'au 31 janvier 2023 deux
systèmes d'information qui ont été mis
en oeuvre sur le fondement de la loi du
la loi du 11 mai 2020 à savoir SIDEP est
contact covid le but de cette audition
de mon point de vue c'est de faire le
bilan sur l'utilisation par le
gouvernement de ces systèmes
d'information dans le contexte où nous
sommes sortis de la crise sanitaire du
moins du point de vue juridique
un deuxième point qui nous occupe est
sur lequel je voudrais vous interroger
c'est celui de l'application tous
anticovide ici ça ne relève pas
directement des systèmes d'information à
lui aussi été mis en oeuvre sur le
fondement de la loi du 11 mai 2020 avec
une utilisation projet notamment pour
permettre l'enregistrement et l'émission
via SIDEP des tests de dépistage dans un
avis vous combien vous recommandiez
d'inciter les utilisateurs à activer la
fonctionnalité de traçage que pendant
les périodes de circulation active du
virus je voudrais savoir également
qu'elle est le bilan que vous tirez de
l'utilisation de cette application sur
lesquelles on était quelques-uns à avoir
émis des réserves
sur les billes en des systèmes
information avec le recul on disposons
j'aimerais que vous puissiez aussi nous
dresser un bilan de tous les outils
numériques qui ont été mobilisés pour
pour y faire face et de ce point de vue
donc le système information SIDEP le
système contexte covid l'application
tous anti covid les passes sanitaires
les passes vaccinaux je rappelle que
vous avez publié 5 avis au Parlement
avec une qui nous ont été une grande
utilité dans celui d'octobre 2020 vous
regrettiez que le gouvernement n'est
transmis aucun élément concret
d'évaluation
sur l'efficacité de ces dispositifs et
j'observe que le Conseil d'analyse
économique a estimé que les passes
avaient notamment permis d'éviter 4000
décès je voudrais savoir si vous êtes en
mesure ou en capacité de corroborer
cette information ou cette analyse et
sur quel élément et puis naturellement
parce qu'on se retrouve à nouveau à la
veille d'un hiver ou les cas épidémiques
sont finalement en hausse même si elles
attirent moins attention de nos
concitoyens je voudrais savoir que
finalement les perspectives que vous
donnez à l'utilisation de ces différents
systèmes d'information et les
recommandations que vous pourriez faire
devant la commission des lois qui
pourrait se retrouver saisie au fond sur
un texte à l'avenir j'avais pas
d'information précise à ce stade mais il
vaut mieux comme on le sait prévenir que
guérir la présidente vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
d'abord pour votre invitation et pour
vos propos liminaires et je vais essayer
de répondre aux interrogations que vous
avez soulevées et naturellement je me
tiendrai à votre disposition après
mon petit exposé pour
répondre aux questions que celui-ci aura
pu susciter peut-être que je parle un
peu plus fort un peu plus près du micro
merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je vous remercie
d'avoir sollicité la CNIL sur le sujet
des traitements automatisés mis en
oeuvre pour lutter contre la covid 19 je
suis accompagné par Hélène guimaubreau
qui est le chef du service de la santé à
l'acnil par Nassera BK service des
affaires économiques par Benjamin Vial
qui est le chef du service des contrôles
sur la santé RH les affaires publiques
et par sherine berrichi qui est la
conseillère parlementaire et relation
institutionnelles de la CNIL comme vous
le savez comme vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président la CNIL a été
amené à se prononcer à de nombreuses
reprises sur les systèmes d'information
que ce soit dans le cadre de ces
missions d'accompagnement des pouvoirs
publics ou de son pouvoir de contrôle a
posteriori
pour commencer il me semble important de
rappeler que la gestion de cette crise a
rendu a rendu nécessaire la création
dans des conditions d'urgence le plus
souvent de nombreux et nouveaux outils
impliquant le traitement d'importants
volumes de données à caractère personnel
en particulier des données sensibles que
sont les données de santé la conception
des nouveaux systèmes d'information
sanitaire et leur calibrage ont soulevé
des questions inédites en matière de
protection des données cela résulte de
l'ampleur des données collectées pour
certains systèmes d'information ce sont
les données d'une majorité de la
population française qui ont ainsi été
collectés et il faut également souligner
la multitude de professionnels devant
pouvoir y accéder en particulier pour
les données de SIDEP vous savez c'est le
système d'information qui recense les
résultats des tests de contact covid
pour les cas contacts et du système
d'information sur les vaccins enfin vous
l'avez aussi rappelé monsieur le
Président de nouvelles technologies ont
été utilisées dans le cadre de
l'application stop covid devenu tous
antico vide et de la gestion spati
sanitaire
ensuite je souhaite souligner que cette
situation exceptionnelle caractérisée
par une crise sanitaire sans précédent
dans notre histoire contemporaine n'a
pas fait obstacle à l'application de la
réglementation sur la protection des
données les principes posés par cette
réglementation ont démontré la grande
robustesse du rgpd le règlement général
sur la protection des données ainsi
qu'une souplesse suffisante pour
permettre le déploiement de divers
outils de gestion de l'épidémie tout en
offrant à l'acnil la possibilité de
contrôler réellement
le respect des droits et des libertés
fondamentaux des personnes et le cas
échéant de demander des corrections en
cas de mauvaises pratiques
ces deux dernières années ont mis en
exergue que la nécessaire prise en
compte de la protection des données à
caractère personnel était un facteur
déterminant pour contribuer à la
confiance des concitoyens pour
contribuer à créer les conditions même
si c'est un terme que j'aime pas
spécialement mais de l'acceptabilité
sociale des solutions proposées et ainsi
garantir une fine l'efficacité des
mesures employées
pendant cette crise la CNIL c'est
particulièrement appliquée à assurer que
les outils utilisés étaient conformes
avec les réglementations applicables en
matière de droit au respect de la vie
privée mais pas uniquement elle a aussi
plus largement veillée au respect
d'autres libertés et droit fondamentaux
que l'acné n'a pas pour vocation
première
protéger d'une façon habituelle c'est la
liberté d'aller venir la liberté
d'entreprendre l'égalité de traitement
des personnes ou encore la liberté de
consentir à un traitement médical ou à
subir un acte médical à cette fin lakni
la mise en oeuvre toutes les missions et
a fait appel à l'ensemble des pouvoirs
qui lui sont dévolus par la loi elle a
également mobilisé de façon
exceptionnelle toutes les ressources à
sa disposition à cet égard tant le
collège de la CNIL et tout
particulièrement Madame Valérie Peugeot
en charge de la santé et tous les agents
de la CNIL on fait preuve d'un
engagement et d'une réactivité
remarquable
cette crise a démontré toute la
pertinence des équilibres organisés par
la loi Informatique et Liberté
alors ça c'était des considérations
introductives un peu général
je voudrais rappeler qu'en amont donc la
CNIL a pu conseiller les pouvoirs
publics à de nombreuses occasions
souvent en urgence sur la conformité des
traitements mis en œuvre à cet égard il
me semble important de souligner la
qualité des échanges que nous avons eu
avec les ministères compétents lors des
phases d'élaboration des textes et de la
conduite des études d'impact il y a eu
un dialogue efficace qui s'est instauré
entre nous et qui a contribué sans aucun
doute à une réelle prise en compte des
principes fondateurs et protecteurs de
la réglementation en matière de
protection des données alors quelques
chiffres depuis 2020 depuis le début de
la crise l'acné l'a rendu 31 avis sur
des projets de textes du gouvernement
elle a été auditionnée à 12 reprises par
le Parlement 13 monsieur le Président
avec cette audition et en tout cas sur
ce sujet
14 la semaine prochaine exactement
madame la difficulté tout à fait
contribuement ainsi je l'espère au fil
des évolutions du cadre juridique a
éclairé les débats parlementaires sur
des enjeux fondamentaux liés au respect
de la vie privée des données à caractère
personnel dans le même temps la CNIL et
le service de la santé tout
particulièrement à instruit près de 170
demandes d'autorisation relatives à des
projets de recherche en lien avec la
crise sanitaire et ce dans des délais
extrêmement courts le plus souvent en
quelques jours et grâce à une procédure
Haddock mise en oeuvre selon la priorité
des demandes
à l'occasion de des conseils que nous
avons adressé au Gouvernement nous avons
fréquemment rappelé vous y faisiez
allusion monsieur le Président la
nécessité d'une évaluation régulière des
dispositifs mis en oeuvre dans le cadre
d'une politique sanitaire qui doit être
vu dans sa globalité
l'objectif de ces évaluations est double
il s'agissait d'une part pendant la
crise ou en tout cas au plus haut de la
crise d'apprécier de la proportionnalité
des dispositifs mis en oeuvre pour
mettre fin le cas échéant à des mesures
qui pouvaient infiner ou au fil de l'eau
s'avérer inutile ou disproportionné mais
il s'agit aujourd'hui maintenant aussi
d'apprendre pour l'avenir d'être à même
de déterminer quels sont les systèmes
d'information et les traitements de
données les plus utiles pour gérer une
crise sanitaire de cette ampleur et
comment les concevoir de façon à
concilier les différents impératifs
protection de la santé protection de la
vie privée
le Parlement a d'ailleurs tenu compte de
la nécessité d'évaluer les mesures
prises puisque finalement chaque année
depuis le début de la crise il y a eu un
texte qui réclamait ses évaluations
l'article 11 de la loi du 11 mai 2020
qui demande un rapport détaillé pour
l'application de deux systèmes
d'information siddep et contact covid
l'article premier de la loi du 31 mai
2021 demandant que le gouvernement
transmette au Parlement un rapport sur
l'impact des mesures prises et les
indicateurs sanitaires qui permettaient
de justifier le maintien de ces systèmes
d'information et puis plus récemment
l'article 5 de la loi du 30 juillet 2022
qui a prescrit au gouvernement de
transmettre au Parlement je cite une
évaluation du cadre juridique en vigueur
y compris en matière de traitement de
données à caractère personnel
alors dans ce contexte l'application
tous anticovid que vous mentionniez
monsieur le Président et le Pass
sanitaire ont fait l'objet de rapport
d'évaluation Haddock qui ont été
transmis à la CNIL
alors en ce qui concerne tout anticovide
après analyse du rapport et sur la base
de ces propres investigations l'acné la
constaté que l'outil qui a été conçu
était particulièrement respectueux de la
vie privée il faut se rappeler que le
traçage des contacts automatiques au
moyen des téléphones était alors
totalement nouveau intraçage par la
puissance publique qui générait
légitimement des craintes parmi nos
concitoyens et pouvait présenter des
risques pour les libertés publiques le
gouvernement associé la CNIL tout au
long de la conception de l'outil et a
tenu grands comptes de ses conseils le
collège de l'acnil a considéré que
l'application pouvait être maintenue en
vigueur compte tenu des garanties
intégrées volontariat strict respect du
principe de minimisation des données
absence de géolocalisation notamment
cependant l'évaluation a montré que
l'application n'a eu qu'une utilité
marginale dans le contact Racing donc il
est important d'en tirer les leçons pour
l'avenir il s'agit notamment de
déterminer à quel moment un outil de ce
type a supposer qu'il soit nécessaire
et le plus utile est-ce que c'est au
début de la circulation d'un virus
particulièrement dangereux pour
identifier un pic de contamination et en
tirer des conséquences au moment où les
enquêtes sanitaires
voilà sont encore maîtrisés en quelque
sorte ou bien faut-il l'utiliser lors de
période de circulation déjà
particulièrement active du virus pour
compléter les enquêtes sanitaires
réalisées manuellement si j'ose dire
au moment où elles sont déjà très très
mobilisées compte tenu de
la circulation très active du virus du
virus nous ne savons pas encore répondre
à ces questions
s'agissant du Pass sanitaire puis du
Pass vaccinal il ressort notamment des
avis du Conseil d'État de juillet et
décembre 2021 qu'ils avaient pour
principaux objectifs de réduire la
probabilité pour les personnes exerçant
des activités à riches de développer et
de transmettre la covid-19 donc réduire
cette transmission et aussi l'autre
objectif c'était de limiter les formes
graves de la maladie et d'alléger
la pression sur le système hospitalier à
cet égard la clinique constate que faute
d'outils permettant de distinguer la
part de réduction des risques de
transmission attribuable au Pass
sanitaire et en l'absence de situation
de référence comparables l'évaluation
révèle que le Pass sanitaire a
principalement contribué à augmenter la
couverture vaccinale ce qui a selon le
rapport contribué à réduire la
propagation du virus et forme grave et
la pression exercée sur le système
hospitalier
le bilan donc de ce point de vue semble
révéler une utilité du Pass mais je
voudrais souligner que le Pass sanitaire
puis vaccinal utilisé
pour inciter à se faire vacciner et
particulièrement attentatoire aux
libertés publiques il ne doit être
réservé qu'à des situations extrêmes
pour un temps tout à fait limité le
Parlement doit me semble-t-il marqué
fortement qu'il n'y a pas d'effet
cliquet comme on dit en économie de ce
point de vue
enfin l'évaluation des systèmes
d'information SIDEP contact covid les
systèmes d'information des agences
régionales de santé les ARS et de
vaccins covid fournis à la CNIL n'a fait
état que d'éléments factuels et chiffrés
portant sur la mise en place de chacun
de ces systèmes d'information et de
traitement dans sa mise en œuvre
individuelle ou dans leur mise en œuvre
individuelle mon sentiment mais qui se
fonde sur la pratique de ces dossiers au
jour le jour à la CNIL et en aucun cas
sur des considérations scientifiques
c'est que la création de SIDEP donc pour
centraliser les résultats des dépistages
et de vaccins covid semble avoir été
légitime même si la CNIL n'est
historiquement pas favorable à la
centralisation des fichiers servante à
l'administration des soins de santé et
c'est une doctrine en quelque sorte qui
a naturellement
comme justification de protéger ces
données particulièrement sensibles que
sont les données de santé des Français
en effet une telle centralisation qui
est déjà par nature particulièrement
intrusive puisque de fait ça consiste à
avoir des listes de personnes dépistées
vaccinés peut présenter des risques de
mes usages de divulgation accidentelle
notamment il peut avoir donc des
conséquences pour les personnes
concernées mais je pense que
il faut resituer cette réflexion dans un
contexte de progression de la
numérisation de la société par exemple
avec la mise en oeuvre du dossier
médical partagé de l'espace numérique en
santé et par ailleurs pour la gestion
d'une crise sanitaire d'une telle
violence une centralisation a pu être
justifiée au vu des caractéristiques de
la crise qui nécessitaient une forte
réactivité pour traiter un très grand
nombre de données pour
transmettre rapidement ces données pour
avoir une vision globale pour réguler
l'accès au vaccin par exemple et le
collège de la CNIL a donc considéré que
dans ces circonstances tout à fait
particulières l'architecture centralisée
de ces systèmes d'information était
admissible
celles qui sont de contact covid et des
systèmes d'information des ARS
principalement utilisées pour les
enquêtes sanitaires je reste si vous me
permettez cette expression un peu
familière monsieur le Président un peu
sur ma faim
sa mission des évaluations je ne
conteste pas le principe de ces
traitements mais il présente des risques
particuliers en termes de protection de
la vie privée ils ont conduit à
collecter et à brasser une quantité
colossale de données
leur utilisation en continu avec une
telle intensité une telle densité
était-elle indispensable elle était son
nul doute légitime mais si nous sommes
confrontés à nouveau à cette situation
ce qui j'espère ne sera pas le cas il
faudra s'interroger sur la possibilité
de calibrer plus finement les choses
le traitement pourrait varier selon le
contexte lorsque la situation du virus
est maîtrisée ou en est encore assez
début ou pour des enquêtes sur des
clusters l'apport du traitement semble
établi mais lors de période de
circulation intense du virus
un tel traitement nécessite de disposer
de moyens suffisants pour collecter et
exploiter surtout efficacement les
données dans le cadre de la gestion de
l'épidémie compte tenu des difficultés
connues c'est à dire qu'il faut pouvoir
mobiliser un grand nombre d'enquêteurs à
former il faut pouvoir mener des
enquêtes dans des délais contraints pour
conserver la pertinence de la
notification et il n'est pas certain que
ça a été en l'espèce le cas au plus fort
de la crise
sans pouvoir porter un jugement
définitif il me semble nécessaire
aujourd'hui que soit établi une analyse
de la complémentarité des dispositifs
ayant été mis en oeuvre à plus forte
raison avant d'envisager une éventuelle
refonte du cadre juridique applicable en
période de crise il ne s'agit nullement
de remettre en cause la légitimité
d'action sanitaire mise en place en
urgence et dans un contexte incertain
mais il est nécessaire d'apprendre de
cette crise
alors je voudrais maintenant brièvement
vous présenter l'action de la CNIL en
aval en quelque sorte donc on a donné
beaucoup d'avis en amont sur les textes
présentés par le gouvernement et
transmis au Parlement mais dès le début
de la crise j'ai annoncé que la CNIL
contrôlerait en continu les fichiers
liés à la gestion de la crise sanitaire
pour répondre au caractère exceptionnel
de la situation et au vu de la
sensibilité des données traitées cela a
mobilisé énormément de ressources mais
je suis convaincue que ça peut-être
aussi contribuer à la confiance que nos
concitoyens pouvaient avoir à l'égard de
l'action des pouvoirs publics c'est
vérifications elles ont porté
principalement sur les conditions
d'information des personnes la
sécurisation des données et leur durée
de conservation le respect en tout cas
de la durée de conservation ainsi depuis
la mise en oeuvre de ces dispositifs en
2020 la commission a procédé à une
cinquantaine de contrôles 52 très
exactement certains sont en cours
d'instruction de nouvelles vérifications
diligentes notamment s'agissant du
système d'information contact covid au
terme de son alimentation que vous avez
prévu au 31 janvier 2023 c'est la loi du
30 juillet 2022 plus globalement je veux
préciser que les investigations se
poursuivent tant que les fichiers sont
utilisés et ne s'achèveront ces
investigations qu'auternes de leur
utilisation on s'attachera notamment à
vérifier à ce moment là que les
différents systèmes d'information ne
sont plus alimentés et que les données
sont bien supprimées à l'issue de leur
durée de conservation
cette démarche de contrôle continue des
outils de gestion de l'équidé de
l'épidémie et vraiment sans équivalent
dans l'histoire de notre institution et
elle a permis de s'assurer de la mise en
conformité des systèmes d'information en
temps réel il en résulte un bilan
globalement positif en matière de
conformité rgpd comme le collège de
l'acnil la souligné dans les 5 avis que
vous avez rappelé monsieur le Président
et qu'elle vous a adressé aucun
dysfonctionnement majeur ou structurel
des systèmes d'information créé pour
lutter contre la crise sanitaire n'a été
relevée cela mérite d'être souligné
compte tenu notamment des conditions
d'urgence dans lesquelles ces systèmes
ont été conçus analysés et déployés
lorsque par ces investigations l'acné
l'a identifié des difficultés notamment
à la suite de violation de données des
modifications techniques ont été opérées
les textes ont été ajustés je pense
notamment à l'information des personnes
à l'encadrement du recours à des
prestataires privés ou à l'amélioration
des mesures de sécurité alors comme
j'étais déjà très longue je vais
maintenant concentrer mon propos sur
les enseignements que nous essayons de
tirer devant vous de
ces éléments tout d'abord la crise a
constitué un puissant accélérateur de la
diffusion numérique dans le domaine de
la santé la place des plateformes en
ligne de prise de rendez-vous médicaux
et les sorts considérables des
téléconsultation
en est une des illustrations
elle a aussi éclairé cette crise
sous un jour nouveau les questions de
souveraineté numérique et je pense à la
plateforme des données du Elf data hub
elle a éclairé aussi les risques en
matière de sécurité des systèmes
d'information l'augmentation des
cyberattaques qui demeurent comme on le
sait tous malheureusement d'actualité la
faiblesse de la culture numérique chez
certains acteurs et sans du tout
généralisé au point de té du doigt qui
que ce soit d'une façon générale
j'évoquerai certains établissements
professionnels de santé certaines ARS et
autres agences publiques
ensuite la CNIL n'est évidemment pas
compétente pour dire si les dispositifs
existants constituaient d'un point de
vue scientifique médical des moyens
suffisants pour lutter contre une
pandémie
pour autant les nombreux textes adoptés
pendant la crise pour permettre le
déploiement en urgence des dispositifs
ont témoigné en tout cas de
l'insuffisance ou de l'incomplétude du
cadre juridique qui existait avant la
crise du covid-19 ces textes ont répondu
à la nécessité dans certains cas précis
de déroger vos secrets médical ce qui ne
peut être fait comme vous le savez mieux
que quiconque par la loi je pense
notamment au système d'information
contact covid décidettes ainsi qu'à des
besoins de transparence quand on
fonctionnement de dispositif nouveau je
pense à l'application traçage numérique
tout son petit covid
par ailleurs une évaluation globale de
ces dispositifs afin d'assurer enfin de
s'assurer de leur complémentarité semble
s'imposer à plus forte raison avant
d'envisager toute éventuel pérennisation
de certains dispositifs déjà mis en
œuvre donc il convient à la lumière de
ce que nous avons vécu depuis presque
déjà trois ans de procéder un état des
lieux objectifs de l'existant et que
s'engage une réflexion dans le cadre
d'un débat démocratique sur le cadre
juridique actuel et les évolutions
nécessaires notons qu'une telle
évaluation s'impose avant la fin de ce
mois en application de l'article 5 de la
loi du 30 juillet 2022 bien que la loi
pris soin de préciser qu'elle ne
concernait que les pandémies et non les
épidémies ou d'autres catastrophes
sanitaires
en outre une réflexion est aussi
susceptible de s'engager sur
l'opportunité de maintenir certains
dispositifs en dehors des périodes de
crise ce débat il va permettre de
cranter dans la loi un certain nombre de
garanties visant à assurer un équilibre
entre l'objectif à valeur
constitutionnelle de protection de la
santé publique et le respect des
libertés fondamentales des personnes
l'accès aux soins la protection des
données à caractère personnel
il conviendra de prendre en compte les
spécificités de chaque crise afin que
les atteintes portées au droit et aux
libertés des personnes concernées
constituent des mesures nécessaires et
proportionnées et par voie de
conséquences il s'agit de déterminer les
critères spécifiques de création ou
d'activation des systèmes d'information
cette vigilance elle plaide donc pour
l'élaboration d'un dispositif à
géométrie variable en toute état de
cause seule des situations d'une
particulière ampleur ou gravité devrait
pouvoir autoriser la mise en oeuvre de
traitement spécifique à fortiori s'ils
sont dérogatoires aux droits communs et
fortement à dentatoire aux droits et
libertés pour ces raisons je forme le
vœu monsieur président que l'acné soit
saisi de tout projet de loi relatif à la
protection des données à caractère
personnel et au traitement de telles
données quand bien même la mise en
oeuvre des traitements en cause devrait
être précisé par voie réglementaire et
je tiens enfin et ça sera quasiment mon
dernier mot avant les questions à
souligner que cette crise sanitaire a
confirmé qu'il était possible de mettre
en oeuvre des traitements de données de
manière efficace et rapide et qui soit
respectueux de la vie privée loin de
constituer des freins à la gestion de la
crise sanitaire le règlement général sur
la protection des données et la loi
Informatique et Liberté ont permis de
garantir la mise en oeuvre effective de
dispositifs respectueux des droits et
libertés des personnes
ils ont ainsi contribué à une
transparence de l'action de l'État à
laquelle le Parlement a par ailleurs
tout particulièrement veillée et qui a
contribué je l'espère à limiter la
défiance de nos concitoyens envers ces
systèmes d'information je vous remercie
pour votre écoute alors que j'ai cru
comprendre que vous vous étiez couché
fort tard et je reste à votre
disposition pour les questions que vous
voudriez pouvoir me poser merci beaucoup
merci madame la Présidente deux
observations avant de donner la parole à
mes collègues pour une durée de 2
minutes chacun d'abord je réponds
positivement à votre demande de
consultation préalable avant tout texte
qui soit nature législatives ou de
nature à déléguer un pouvoir législatif
pour pouvoir réglementaire sur la
question de la protection des données et
j'ai cru comprendre et sera une question
complémentaire que je vous pose que vous
regrettiez comme je l'ai fait en
commission mixte paritaire et lors de
l'actualité le fait d'avoir rayé d'un
trade plume tout le dispositif
législatif qui avait été édifiée pire
après pierre sur la question l'état
d'urgence SAN et qui était le fruit
finalement d'une réflexion parlementaire
assez riche sur la question des limites
ou l'état d'urgence sanitaire et qui
figurait de mon code de la santé
publique je n'apparaux pour une durée de
2 minutes
oui madame la Présidente d'abord merci
de votre venue et de votre intervention
j'étais responsable pour la majorité
lors du débat
et du vote sur le rgpd dans notre
commission et pour notre institution et
nous avons bien pensé à vous pendant la
crise covid je dis cela parce que nous
avions déjà à l'époque mais on était
loin de penser ce qui allait arriver
beaucoup réfléchit sur ce couple
protéger les données et en même temps
diffuser les données et notamment en
matière scientifique pour les
professionnels pour les chercheurs pour
aujourd'hui et pour demain finalement
pour tirer des conclusions essayez
d'améliorer des dispositifs pour la
suite un débat notamment sur
anonymisation ou cryptonomisation ou
pseudonomisation des données je me
rappelle comme si c'était hier parce que
il y avait eu vraiment des débats très
chauds là dessus donc je voudrais savoir
justement en allant un peu plus loin par
rapport au RG
comment vous ressentez la chose est-ce
qu'il y a encore des améliorations à
apporter sur cette question précise où
est-ce que finalement le dispositif a
plus ou moins bien tenu et puis deuxième
question c'est ce des moyens de l'acné
c'est pour ça que j'ai aussi beaucoup
pensé à vous parce que certes après le
rgpd on vous avait donné un certain
nombre de moyens complémentaires pour
réaliser l'ensemble de vos tâches il n'y
a pas que les tâches en matière de
données de santé il y a l'ensemble
évidemment du dispositif est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous diriez que c'est
suffisant ou est-ce qu'il y aurait là
encore des moyens complémentaires à
donner pour que vous puissiez mieux
réaliser encore c'est ces politiques qui
sont absolument essentielles pour nos
libertés mais aussi pour notre vie en
société d'une manière générale
merci Monsieur Jean-François Coulomme
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente de l'acnil
comme tout système informatique on fait
on est confronté à des flux de données
il y a la création de ces données leur
stockage la diffusion la transmission
alors moi j'aurais aimé savoir si vous
êtes en mesure de donner des
informations sur qui est-ce qui
centralise les données qui sont ainsi
collectées quel type de serveurs à qui
appartiennent-ils quelles sont leurs
nationalité parce que il y a eu des
débats et des questionnements
il y a quelques mois déjà maintenant au
début de la crise covid justement sur
la nature et la propriété des serveurs
donc voilà une question sur les serveurs
ensuite qui décide à qui sont transmises
ces données est-ce qu'il y a une
autorité supérieure indépendante ou
c'est le propriétaire du du logiciel par
exemple pour ce qui concerne le stop
covid
donc quels sont les les droits
finalement affectés au détenteur des
données pour ensuite décider de qui en
est le destinataire ou l'utilisateur du
moins
et ensuite vous avez donc des organismes
qui sont censés assurer l'accompagnement
social
par exemple des agents de service
préfectoraux qui accorde ses droits aux
agents préfectoraux là ces services
préfectoraux donc vous voyez on a quand
même un certain nombre de questions
également sur les garanties mais vous
avez évoqué le fait que vous y étiez
vigilant mais de quelle manière
et la dernière question porte sur
finalement le droit d'accès et de
révocation de ces données par les
propriétaires qui sont on va dire les
particuliers comment on fait pour avoir
un système simple de d'annulation ou de
suppression ou d'accès du moins à toutes
ces données voilà merci madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur Emmanuel
Mandon oui merci monsieur le président
madame la présidente depuis sa création
en 1978 ainsi que vous l'indiquiez
vous-même lors de précédentes auditions
et encore aujourd'hui la CNIL s'attache
à la défense de la protection de la vie
privée des libertés individuelles en
particulier la protection de nos données
personnelles qui recouvrent des enjeux
de plus en plus larges et complexes
alors le groupe démocrate que je
représente et lui aussi très attaché à
cette protection il l'a montré à chaque
fois que cela est nécessaire
comme lors de l'examen des différents
textes relatifs à la crise sanitaire
mon collègue Philippe la tombe a apporté
d'ailleurs notre voie sur ces sujets et
plus particulièrement sur lui des
traitements automatisés dans le cadre de
la lutte contre les covid-19 et j'ai
également pu rappeler notre attachement
juillet dernier lors de la discussion
générale du projet de loi met enfin au
régime d'exception créé pour lutter
contre l'épidémie liée à la covid 19
alors l'irruption continue de nouvelles
technologies comme ça a été souligné
conjugué à l'omnipré présence des
traitements de données personnelles dans
tous les domaines de la vie constituent
un effet un défi permanent pour la CNIL
et pour notre société bien sûr vous avez
rappelé le rôle de la rgpd
et ce rôle de régulation de la CNIL une
combinaison fort heureuse et notamment
dans le cadre de ce que nous venons de
vivre alors vous avez rappelé des
principes nous sommes tout à fait
conscients de l'importance de cette
action le bilan vous paraît globalement
positif alors aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire par rapport au moyen
dont vous disposez c'était posé comme
question et puis enfin je voudrais
savoir si l'application tout antigo vide
que vous semblez vous avez peut-être mis
en doute un peu son utilité finalement
est-ce qu'elle reste un outil
indispensable pour la suite merci Madame
Edwige Diaz
oui merci beaucoup alors l'acné alerté à
plusieurs reprises sur les risques de
dispositif à tentatoires à la vie privée
selon vos propres termes telles que le
Pass sanitaire dans une délibération de
la CNIL on peut lire je cite il est
essentiel que l'impact des différents
dispositifs numériques sur la stratégie
sanitaire globale soit étudiée et
documentée régulièrement à partir de
données objectives afin de s'assurer que
le recours à ce type de dispositif
prenne fin dès que leur nécessité
disparaîtra vous avez mis en cause
l'utilisation des données du Pass
sanitaire par mail car cela les rendait
accessibles à tous de façon indéterminée
il semble également que vous ayez dû
rappeler à l'ordre une fédération
sportive à ce sujet mais sans la
sanctionner aujourd'hui pouvez-vous nous
dire ce qu'il est advenu des données
insérées dans les passes sanitaires
alors que celui-ci n'est plus en vigueur
ou et comment sont conservés ces données
qui a accès et combien de temps sera
encore tel conservées je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Hervé Soulignac
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la Présidente pour votre exposé
vous l'avez rappelé avec avec vos mots
et peut-être le faire un peu
différemment mais la population
française a consenti à ce qu'une partie
de sa vie soit collectée et ce sont des
données en masque à la confié à la
puissance publique pour lutter contre
contre le virus mais les Français n'ont
pas je crois consenti à la pérennisation
de ces dispositifs et s'interroge
aujourd'hui sur la nécessité de les
maintenir compte tenu de l'état
sanitaire que nous connaissons même si
l'outil est respectueux de la vie privée
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'on a
centralisé des données de santé qu'on a
donc créé un risque de violation de de
la vie privée qui n'existait pas moi
j'aurai deux deux questions dans ce
contexte là vous posez d'abord
s'agissant d'application tous anticovid
est-ce que vous pouvez décomposer les
usages qui en sont faits aujourd'hui je
rappelle que ce qui fondait
le lancement de cette application au
départ c'était le contact tracing vous
nous avez dit que il avait été marginal
dans son dans son usage donc je voudrais
savoir quels sont déjà les usages
aujourd'hui qui sont faits de tous
antico vide est-ce que ce dispositif
garde du sens dès lors qu'il n'y a plus
de passes sanitaire et est-ce que pour
poser ma question peut-être de manière
un peu triviale n'est-il pas temps
d'éteindre ces dispositifs
merci Monsieur Philippe Pradal
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente avant tout merci pour pour
l'exposé très clair dont je ne
retiendrai de façon un peu caricaturale
que le bilan globalement positif que
vous posez même si ça ne rappelle pas
que de bons souvenirs un certain nombre
de personnes qui ont les cheveux blancs
je m'appuierais et je ne ferai que
prolonger la la réflexion du président
Houllier sur le fait qui a été barré un
certain nombre de dispositifs ou qu'on
disparu plutôt du code de la santé
publique un certain nombre de
dispositifs dans un monde où les crises
vont probablement s'enchaîner vous avez
évoqué la doctrine que pose la CNIL sur
un certain nombre de sujets
est-il envisageable enfin comment la
CNIL pourrait contribuer à élaboration
d'une doctrine qui permettrait face à
des crises ou à dépend des MI
malheureusement probable d'activer les
systèmes un peu plus en anticipation de
les travailler un peu plus en amont et
de capitaliser sur le travail important
qui a été effectué tant par les
autorités de l'État la CNIL et le
Parlement de façon à ne plus être
forcément réaction au dernier moment et
à posteriori mais plutôt en anticipation
en ayant un corpus doctrinal auquel vous
pourriez contribuer qu'il soit plus
conceptuel et non pas en réaction à des
situations précises merci merci monsieur
jérémyordanov
oui bonjour merci beaucoup pour cette
état des lieux que je veux vraiment
saluer
effectivement on comprend qu'il y a une
amélioration un des des dispositifs en
vigueur suite à vos à vos avis à votre
contrôle
je veux
m'associer à aux avis que vous rendez
parfois notamment sur le risque
d'accoutumance et de banalisation des
descriptifs dérogatoires aux droits
communs et que
ces mesures ne peuvent être justifiées
que si elles sont efficaces
éprouvées et à ce titre vous notez sur
le Pass sanitaire qui est une mesure
particulièrement attentive attentatoires
aux libertés publiques qu'elle a pas eu
un effet
direct a eu un effet sur la couverture
vaccinale mais pas nécessairement
proportionné sur la limitation de la
population du virus
par ailleurs je veux vous poser la
question des moyens financiers et des
moyens d'investigation de la CNIL et ce
que vous jugez qu'ils sont suffisants au
regard des enjeux en présence
et est-ce que sur la question des
prérogatives que vous avez et ce qu'une
question de l'autocuisine par exemple
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait être
intéressant pour la Cnil
merci Madame esafossillon
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente au-delà du nombre de fois où
vous avez été auditionné les avis de la
CNIL ont largement
occupé
nos débats ici lors du dernier projet de
loi avec mon groupe tout au long des
débats sur le traitement le partage et
la récolte des données de santé nous
avons dit nos craintes sur les dangers
d'un fichier d'une telle ampleur sur des
prorogations qui nous semblent à chaque
fois bien trop longue et sur évidemment
au regard des protections
constitutionnelles et conventionnelles
du droit au respect à la vie privée les
dangers que pouvaient représenter ces
différentes applications et ces
différents recueils de traitement de
données je crois que ça a recoupé pour
une part d'ailleurs peut-être que vous
les exprimez moins maintenant parce que
du travail a été fait mais en tout cas
ça exprimait les premiers avis fait par
la CNIL au démarrage
moi j'ai plusieurs questions même si
pour une part vous avez déjà commencé à
tracer quelques lignes de réponse il y a
le collec Solignac qui disait est-ce
qu'il est pas tant d'éteindre maintenant
d'arriver à l'extinction de ces données
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner
quelques parts des préconisations sur la
méthode de l'extinction parce que je
pense qu'elle est importante si nous
décidons d'y venir ensuite dans une
délibération du 19 mai 2022 vous avez
invité les responsables des traitements
vaccins covid et SIDEP à relever le
niveau de sécurité des systèmes et à
mettre à jour leur analyse d'impact sur
la protection des données est-ce que
cette sollicitation a été prise en
compte et quels sont les risques
identifiés liés à la sécurité numérique
des données de santé je pense à l'âme
saunage à l'escroquerie etc est-ce que
vous pourriez en dire quelques mots je
vois que j'arrivais au bout donc je vais
éliminer quelques questions mais dans un
avis sur le suivi numérique des
personnes la scène la scène cdH alerté
sur un effet cliquet
recours à ces dispositifs numériques
craignant une
accoutumance et vous avez aussi émis des
craintes je relève à cet égard la
tentative du ministère de l'Économie
d'accéder à des données bancaires des
Français pensez-vous que le gouvernement
a suffisamment informé la population de
manière claire transparente sur
l'existence de ces différentes
traitements je vous remercie
on avait presque tenu les délais jusqu'à
présent
madame la Présidente pour répondre à
cette première série de questions s'il
vous plaît merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président et merci pour toutes ces
questions qui brassent vraiment les
principales problématiques auxquelles on
a été confronté
alors sur
l'état d'urgence sanitaire monsieur le
Président
sur l'éventuelles pérennisation
éventuellement c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
un projet de loi je crois à la fin de
l'année 2020 qui n'a pas vu le jour et
donc c'est assez délicat pour la Cnil
c'est l'histoire de l'éventuelle
pérennisation de certains de ces
dispositifs outre le fait qu'on n'a pas
de compétences sanitaire ou
scientifiques particulières de se
prononcer
en l'absence de texte en savoir quel
système d'information plutôt que tel
autre éventuellement prolongeable
voilà ce que je peux dire à ce stade en
tout cas sur ce sujet même si j'ai
essayé de dire dans mon exposé que en
tout état de cause et je rebondis sur
l'effet cliquet effectivement il faudra
retenir le cas échéant qu'un dispositif
à géométrie variable fondée vraiment sur
la nécessité et la proportionnalité au
cas par cas de l'usage de tel ou tel
système d'information il s'agit pas du
tout en tout cas dans notre esprit parce
que c'est arrivé une fois et dans des
circonstances dramatiques de copier
coller si j'ose dire en quelque sorte
l'ensemble d'un dispositif qui était
extrêmement particulier il y a des
circonstances précises
[Musique]
posait des questions sur la recherche en
tout cas ce que je peux dire c'est que
le rgpd la CNIL n'ont pas été un frein à
la recherche dans le domaine de la santé
parce que la plupart des vous savez que
la clinique des livres des autorisations
en matière de recherche en santé mais et
donc en l'espèce il y a eu des
recherches naturellement liées à la
covid-19 mais la CNIL ne délivre des
autorisations que si les projets de
recherche ne sont pas conformes aux
méthodologies de référence que la CNIL a
elle-même émise et je parle sous
contrôle de la chaîne du service de la
santé mais 85% des demandes qu'on a eu
sur des recherches concernant la
covid-19 était conforme à des
méthodologies de référence donc on
n'avait pas délivré d'autorisation et
dans les autres cas puisqu'on a délivré
le 370 autorisations en matière de
recherche liées à la à la covid 19
la plupart du temps pour 70% de ces cas
en moins d'une semaine vraiment en
quelques jours parce que on vous avez
mis en place une adresse mail dédiée mis
des équipes enfin accentuer la
disponibilité des équipes des
matérialiser des décisions et surtout
commencer à traiter en amont en lien
avec les chercheurs en quelque sorte la
pré-instruction des dossiers donc du
point de vue de la recherche sur la
covid la CNIL a vraiment accompagné les
acteurs afin de trouver des solutions
qui permettaient de respecter les
modalités de recueil du consentement des
personnes dont les données faisaient
l'objet de recherche
et on s'est beaucoup attaché aussi aux
modalités d'information de ces personnes
donc le processus tel qu'il existe en
tout cas il n'est pas bloquant
voilà ce que il est d'autant moins
d'ailleurs qu'il y a un article de la
loi Informatique et Liberté qui permet
aussi à certains organismes listés par
un arrêté de réaliser sans autorisation
de la CNIL des traitements de données de
façon temporaire dans le domaine de la
santé
mais en tout état de cause il faut bien
s'attacher à déterminer les catégories
de données pouvant faire l'objet d'un
traitement à des fins de suivi de
recherche vous avez évoqué toutes les
subtilités que les spécialistes
enfin dans les spécialistes raffolent
entre anonymisation pseudonymisation etc
on en est très sensible effectivement
notamment la réutilisation de données
pseudonymisées on pense qu'il faut
exclure un certain nombre de données les
noms les prénoms le numéro de sécurité
sociale qu'on appelle le NIR l'adresse
et les coordonnées de contact
téléphonique ou électroniques des
personnes notamment et tout ça c'est pas
purement conceptuel ou pour faire du
droit pour faire du droit on voit bien
chacun d'entre nous qui a des fuites de
données dans le domaine de la santé ça
rejoint en quelque sorte la
préoccupation cyber sur laquelle je
reviendrai et finalement les individus
ils prennent conscience de la des enjeux
en matière de sécurité quand ce sont
leurs propres données c'est bien normal
qui sont concernés qui se retrouvent
dans la nature les données d'un
laboratoire les données de tests de
dépistage qui était supposés alimentés
SIDEP etc
voilà ce que je peux dire sur la
recherche sur les moyens de la CNIL
c'est une préoccupation que vous avez
exprimée tout comme Monsieur Mandon
ce que je peux dire c'est que il y a une
prise de conscience en tout cas des
pouvoirs publics des et la crise
sanitaire il y a certainement contribué
et j'espère que la réaction de l'acné au
moment de la crise sanitaire a été un
facteur et également déterminant ce sens
les pouvoirs publics ont mieux doté
depuis quelques années
la CNIL en ETP comme on dit en jargon
budgétaire en emploi à temps plein
qu'auparavant puisqu'à la fin de l'année
prochaine les effectifs de la CNIL
atteindront 290 personnes et c'est une
augmentation d'un tiers en l'espace de 3
ou 4 ans à peu près cela étant dit
la CNIL reste petite il ose dire par
rapport à des autorités de protection
des données comparables et qui ont le
même pér je pense même s'ils ne font
plus partie de l'Union européenne à
notre homologue britannique là ici au
qui a trois fois plus de moyens je pense
à
[Musique]
l'autorité de protection des données
allemandes certes dans un système
fédéral mais qui a 4 fois plus de
d'agents que la CNIL et a fortiori dans
l'espèce de
révolution réglementaire qui s'annonce
avec le paquet numérique européen tous
les textes que vous connaissez le DMA le
DSA le datac
un projet de règlement sur l'intelligent
artificielle etc il y a un sujet de
savoir qui va contrôler concrètement ces
dispositions je pense que la CNIL a ça
part à prendre sur un certain nombre des
dispositions de ces textes qui
concerne beaucoup les données à
caractère personnel et aussi de
nouvelles compétences que je souhaite
est-ce que le collège de l'acné le
souhaite et le choix à la CNIL bah par
définition il faudra proportionner en
tout cas pour certaines d'entre eux les
moyens de l'acné en conséquence
alors après monsieur Coulogne demandait
quel type de serveur était utilisé de
quelle nationalité qui décide qui sont
transmis les données et la question du
droit d'accès et de la révocation
alors les solutions des systèmes
d'information covid
à ma connaissance les serveurs étaient
bien français SIDEP par exemple c'était
les serveurs de l'AP-HP mais vous posez
une question
tout à fait importante par exemple sur
le Pass sanitaire on a eu des échanges
avec le ministère de la Santé qui à un
moment a pu envisager d'utiliser un
acteur américain pour des solutions
justement qui permettaient des mesures
de sécurité
l'antidéos comme on dit mais après des
discussions notamment avec la CN le
mystère de la Santé a choisi de basculer
chez un acteur français mais d'une façon
générale le collège de la CNIL est
extrêmement attentif à ce que les
données soient hébergées quitte à ce
qu'elles utilisent ce qui est-ce que les
opérateurs utilisent des technologies
étrangères mais que les données soient
hébergées par des structures qui sont
exclusivement soumis aux droits français
et européen très concrètement pour
limiter l'accès
des données à fortiori quand il s'agit
de donner de santé de donner de sensible
à des acteurs étrangers qui n'ont pas le
même niveau de garantie sur les données
que nous nous avons en France et en
Europe sur les droits donc pour répondre
à la question du député colonne on a
évidemment été très attentifs à la
garantie des droits vous évoquiez le ce
qu'on appelle nous le droit d'opposition
parfois c'est vous-même qui avait exclu
en quelque sorte le droit d'opposition
mais ça se très bien par exemple pour le
système d'information sur les vaccins
vous faites vacciner vous n'avez pas le
choix vous avez votre nom dans un
fichier mais c'est aussi pour des
raisons de pharmaco vigilance que vous
avez dû prendre en compte en revanche il
est clair que
la réglementation en matière de
protection des données prévoient un
ensemble de droits sur l'information sur
ces données le droit d'accès de
rectification le cas échéant et
si certains droits peuvent être
restreints comme l'exemple que je viens
de prendre en matière de crise sanitaire
c'est limitations elles doivent être
inscrites dans un texte qui a été pris
après avis de la CNIL et il faut que les
individus en soi informés de même que le
consentement du patient infecté par
exemple doit être recueilli pour que son
identité soit communiquée aux personnes
considérées comme cas contact
de même qu'une vigilance
hier s'impose pour les données couvertes
par le secret médical
et dans la mesure du possible seul des
professionnels de santé devraient
pouvoir y avoir accès même si à des
contacts covid contenus du volume de
données et de la nécessité d'élargir le
vivier de personnes pouvant y accéder
pour pouvoir recontacter des personnes
un texte justement la loi a dû
élargir cette catégorie
d'acteurs ou en tout cas demander à ce
que ça soit renvoyé au niveau
réglementaire donc il faut pouvoir
aménager et voir comment on peut
aménager des dérogations au secret
médical et encore une fois là est si
dette et contact covid ont fait l'objet
de dérogation
alors Monsieur Mandon nous posait la
question des moyens de la CNIL vous
posiez monsieur le député aussi
enfin vous revenez sur le sujet tous
anti covid finalement
effectivement cette application de
traçage numérique à concentré beaucoup
des débats et des interrogations pendant
la crise covid puisque c'était la
première fois qu'il y avait une
application de traçage étatique
nous nous avons beaucoup travaillé nous
avons un partenariat avec l'INRIA sur
pour nous assurer que ce dispositif soit
commandé dans notre jargon privacy by
design c'est à dire intègre dès sa
conception des considérations de vie
privée donc c'était un dispositif est
basé sur le volontariat
qui ne faisait pas de la géolocalisation
avec le minimum de données des données a
prior le nom
identifiant donc
il nous a semblé que dans la balance
atteinte à la vie privée le dispositif
pouvait être maintenu mais comme il a
été dit nous avons demandé en tout cas
dans notre dernière avis à ce que les
gens n'activent pas la fonctionnalité de
traçage finalement quand la circulation
du virus est faible et c'est un peu
comme les téléphones portables qui
servent à beaucoup de choses sauf à
téléphoner l'application tous anticoïde
elle sert à des tas d'autres
fonctionnalités on l'a vu
stocker des certificats des passes
recueillir des informations pour savoir
où vous pouvez vous faire des vacciné
dépister etc donc dans la balance
utilité marginale je crois que c'est le
terme même du rapport qui nous a été
transmis et faible atteinte à la
protection de la vie privée il a semblé
au collège de l'acné que cette
activation fait que cette application
pouvait être le contenu mais le moins
longtemps possible et le fait est
d'ailleurs que
si je ne me trompe pas elle doit
disparaître cette application le 31
janvier 2023 et naturellement dans le
cadre des contrôles que j'évoquais pour
nous assurer de l'extinction de ces
dispositifs nous y veillerons tous
particulièrement sachant que de toute
façon les données collectées dans le
cadre de tout senti covid
ne sont pas
à ma connaissance
conservée en tout cas pour une durée
extrêmement limitée d'une quinzaine de
jours en fait donc ça voilà
donc ça c'était pour essayer de répondre
à Monsieur Mandon
[Musique]
alors madame Diaz
posé la question
des données insérées dans le Pass
sanitaire
donc d'abord la loi du 31 mai 2021
modifié et son décret d'applications
interdisent la conservation des données
du Pass sanitaire elle ne sont utilisées
que pendant le contrôle en quelque sorte
du Pass sanitaire il y a des garanties
fortes qui ont été poussées par l'acné
légalement sur ce sujet
et on a fait des contrôles pour nous
assurer précisément que ces données
n'étaient pas conservées on a beaucoup
insisté en termes de pédagogie pour que
ce soit uniquement le oui ou le nom qui
apparaît c'est pas l'ensemble des
données sauf pour le Pass utilisé pour
les déplacements hors de France qui
nécessitent pour des raisons
d'interopérabilité entre les
ces différents pays qui est davantage de
donner donc on a été
très
très vigilant sur ces différents sujets
monsieur Soulignac posait la question de
tout senti covid donc dont j'ai essayé
de rappeler le côté couteau suisse avec
plusieurs fonctionnalités donc contact
racine contact Racing statistiques sur
la crise sanitaire le stockage du Pass
qui est encore utilisé aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs pour stocker le Pass européen
puisque ce covid certificate est en
vigueur jusqu'en juin 2023
donc ça je crois que sur tout son petit
covid j'ai déjà répondu alors ça garde
du sens en tout cas ça va pas en garder
très longtemps parce que donc le 31
janvier 2023 il y aura une extinction de
tout son petit covid
monsieur Pradal posait la question de
savoir si la CNIL pouvait contribuer à
une doctrine et pas être en réaction
c'est un peu j'imagine peut-être
effectivement
peut-être un des objets de cette
audition le fait que vous allez devoir
probablement réfléchir à la Py à la
pérennisation de certains
dispositifs donc j'ai fait quelques kva
tout à l'heure quelques avertissements
pour dire que l'acné n'était pas
compétente sur le plan sanitaire et
médical que ça ça nous est difficile de
nous prononcer et à des faux pour moi
parce que c'est quand même le collège de
la CNIL qui prend des décisions sans qui
est bien représentée ici d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui sans pouvoir
répondre sur un texte ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que vraiment finalement et c'est
toute l'activité de la CNIL d'une façon
générale il s'agit de concilier souvent
la protection de la vie privée avec
d'autres impératifs qui sont également
importants qui sont souvent protégés qui
font l'objet d'une protection
constitutionnelle le droit à la santé la
sécurité publique etc
donc nous notre rôle c'est de veiller à
ce qui est des garanties en tout cas
pour les citoyens
pour
le droit à l'information que ces
traitements soient nécessaires qu'ils
soient proportionnés qu'on collecte le
moins de données possible qu'elles
soient conservées le moins longtemps
possible de vérifier qu'il est le moins
d'accédents possible que les personnes
qui accèdent puissent avoir une
traçabilité en cas de mes usages pour
comprendre qui a fait quoi à quel moment
que ces systèmes dure le moins longtemps
possible
donc ça on est capable naturellement de
décliner un peu les grands principes
fondamentaux du droit de la protection
des données nous ce qu'on pense c'est
qu'il faut prendre vraiment en compte
les spécificités de chaque crise les
critères spécifiques d'activation des
différents systèmes
il faut aussi peut-être définir les les
termes quand va-t-on activer le cas
échéance il s'était nécessaire des
systèmes d'information un peu
dérogatoire en droit commun et ce que
c'est qu'est-ce que une situation
sanitaire exceptionnelle qu'est-ce
qu'une crise qui décide de cette
activation monsieur le Président est-ce
que c'est le législateur le gouvernement
une agence quelle autorité
il faut définir les organismes qui sont
concernés par ces dispositifs définir
quasiment
l'autodestruction ou la date de
péremption des systèmes d'information
qui serait le cas échéant
mis en oeuvre donc prévoir en tout cas
des durées limitées seule la loi permet
de déroger au secret médical
même si après les conditions de mise en
oeuvre de celui-ci ou de cette exception
peuvent être précisées par décret en
Conseil d'État après avis de la CNIL
donc j'imagine mais vous le savez mieux
que moi que législateur est là pour
prévoir un cadre global déterminer les
conditions de mise en oeuvre qui doivent
varier en fonction des caractéristiques
de la crise notamment
donc j'espère avoir répondu à Monsieur
Pradal
monsieur
jordanov possède la question des moyens
financiers donc ça en tout cas moyen
financiers on est assez peu gourmand on
est assez on parle beaucoup de sobriété
en ce moment on est assez sobre nous
aussi je dois dire sur le plan
budgétaire peut peut-être trop il
faudrait peut-être qu'on investisse
aussi
davantage on a effectivement une
trentaine de contrôleurs une quinzaine
dans le service de
Benjamin Vial c'est probablement pas
assez sachant que ce sont des binômes un
juristes et un spécialiste des systèmes
d'information en informaticien à chaque
fois pour vous voulez toutes les
entreprises de France et toutes les
administrations même si on fait pas que
des contrôles sur place on fait aussi
des contrôles en ligne des contrôles sur
audition des contrôles sur pièces etc et
que quand on fait un contrôle dans un
secteur déterminé on peut espérer que
compte tenu des résultats qui sont
publiés ou pas mais très souvent rendu
public c'est un effet boule de neige
quand même sur l'ensemble d'un secteur
d'autant plus qu'on travaille avec les
têtes de réseau pour essayer de faire en
sorte qu'elle diffuse elle-même auprès
de leurs
administrer en quelque sorte client
les bonnes pratiques en tout cas on fait
beaucoup d'accompagnement la CNIL c'est
pas juste un gendarme de la protection
des données d'ailleurs on reçoit 14000
plein de parents
c'est presque le double par rapport à ce
qui se passait avant le rgpd on a pensé
la première année que c'était un effet
bulle un effet rgpd ça n'est pas retombé
donc il y a vraiment une prise de
conscience de plus en plus importante de
nos concitoyens par rapport aux enjeux
de la protection de la vie privée tant
mieux mais nous il faut qu'on puisse
suivre et infine et moi je le prends
chaque année en tout cas l'année
dernière par exemple 135 mise en demeure
la formation restreinte de la CNIL et la
commission des sanctions auprès de
laquelle je peux aiguiller un certain
nombre de dossiers mais à laquelle je ne
participe pas a rendu 18 sanctions
l'année dernière à prononcé 18 sanctions
c'est trois fois plus que ce qui se
passait avant le rgpd pour des montants
beaucoup plus importants 218 millions
d'euros l'année dernière beaucoup à
l'encontre des gafams notamment beaucoup
sur le sujet des cookies des une autre
forme de traçage en quelque sorte
mais vous voyez que la disproportion
entre les 14000 plaintes ou le hiatus
entre les 14000 plaintes 135 mise en
demeure et 18 sanctions ça prouve que
même dans le traitement des plaintes on
fait de l'accompagnement parce qu'on
revient vers l'organisme qui a fait
l'objet d'une plainte qui le plus
souvent se mettent en conformité
donc mais il nous faudrait évidemment
davantage de contrôleur de l'auto-césine
on en fait si j'ose dire on se on se
oui oui on en fait que ce soit sur les
contrôles rien n'empêche à la CNIL de
prendre des positions publiques sur tel
ou tel point vous nous y aider on nous
invitant dans ces commissions donc on
vous remercie beaucoup
voilà donc on se sent pas a priori
limité de ce point de vue là alors
madame faussillon posait la question de
savoir s'il fallait
pas sur le l'extinction de ces
systèmes d'information et leur
préconisations
et il est préconisations méthodologique
donc en tout cas
tous les systèmes d'information sauf le
système d'information sur les vaccins
mais peut-être pour des raisons de
pharmacovid il lance ont une date
d'extinction qui est maintenant proche
qui est prév et je parle même pas du
passe qui est terminé comme vous le
savez depuis juillet dernier ont une
date d'extinction qui est prévue entre
le train 31 janvier prochain et le 30
juin prochain pour CINEP donc vraiment
ça sera notre rôle et le rôle des
services des contrôles de la CNIL d'allé
s'assurer d'une part que c'est système
d'information ne sont plus alimentés par
des données et d'autres parts qui aucune
donnée qui était conservée autre que
pour des finalités de recherche le cas
échéance il savait été prévu de façon
pseudonymiser etc
voilà vous vous posiez la question
de la très très légitime de la cyber
sécurité
c'est pour nous une préoccupation
essentielle la CNIL est vraiment un
acteur majeur de la cybersécurité je me
permets de le préciser parce que à ce
stade le rgpd c'est vraiment un allié de
la cybersécurité c'est le seul texte qui
impose des obligations de moyens pas de
résultats naturellement mais de moyens
il faut avoir fait un certain nombre
avoir pris un certain nombre de mesures
pour l'ensemble des responsables de
traitement en France qui soient publics
ou privés
dont ce secteur et en 2021 donc en plein
cœur de la crise on a vu qu'il y avait
un pic de notification des violations
données auprès de la clinique vous savez
c'est une obligation du rgpd maintenant
dans les 72 heures
au cours desquelles un responsable de
traitement s'aperçoit que ces données
ont été violées ou compromises il doit
notifié cette violation à la CNIL s'il
est donnée présente enfin si cette
relation présente un certain nombre de
caractéristiques c'est important si elle
porte sur des données sensibles etc et
en 2021 on a eu aujourd'hui on reçoit
près de 5000 notifications par an en
2021 18% des notifications concernaient
la santé contre 8% l'année précédente de
l'ensemble des notifications
sur ces
violations d'une façon générale et en
tout cas pour la santé
66% des notifications de violation qu'on
a reçu en 2021 qui concernait la santé
correspondait à du piratage dans
piratage on met les rançons judiciaires
vous savez chiffrer les données contre
souvent le paiement d'une rançon pour
pouvoir les déchiffrer et le hameçonnage
donc l'utilisation malveillante de ces
données 66% en 2021 donc de
d'action malveillantes en quelque sorte
dans les notifications qu'on a reçu
concernant la santé contre 40 points de
moins l'année précédente
26%. enfin ou en 2019 en tout cas donc
on voit que vraiment le secteur de la
santé est particulièrement ciblé et la
taxe CHU de Bordeaux les données
compromises et envoyer dans la nature
pour non paiement de la rançon par le
l'hôpital de Corbeil-Essonnes ce sont ce
sont les faces immergées de l'iceberg
mais il y a bien d'autres naturellement
[Musique]
attaquent et on peut penser qu'en 2021
la hausse des cyberattaques la fatigue
des personnels des nouveaux process mise
en oeuvre dans l'urgence ont pu
contribuer à cette surchauffe en quelque
sorte en matière de risque de sécurité
qui est un peu retombée soi-même
d'ailleurs on peut on peut noter que
l'annecy puisque nous sommes dans le
cybermois a fait du thème des rançons
logicielles et du hameçonnage son thème
annuels de ce cybermois et la CNIL
parallèlement indépendamment des actions
qu'elle mène sur la cybersécurité en
termes de pédagogie par exemple je vous
invite à aller sur le site de la CNIL si
vous voulez taper mot de passe si vous
voulez avoir un mot de passe robuste on
a un générateur de mot de passe on des
choses toutes simples mais c'est par là
que ça passe et maintenant sont plutôt
les PME les TPE les PME en quelque sorte
les collectivités locales le secteur de
la santé qui peuvent être les maillons
faibles par rapport à toute une chaîne
d'utilisation de la donnée ou les
grandes structures les grandes
entreprises sont quand même mieux
sécuriser on fait beaucoup
d'accompagnement par ailleurs du
ministère de la Santé sur les questions
de cyberge je pense à l'espace numérique
en santé aux préoccupations de sécurité
dans le dossier médical projet au
système d'information du Samu enfin un
certain nombre de dispositions donc
c'est vraiment un sujet qui nous
préoccupe parce qu'il faut faire
progresser globalement le niveau de
sécurité de l'écosystème notamment dans
le secteur de la santé et on espère y
contribuer par nos actions temps
d'accompagnement que de contrôle
j'espère monsieur le Président avoir
répondu sauf sur l'effet cliquet et
évidemment l'accoutumance qu'on appelle
les solutionnisme technologiques il faut
pas tous ces systèmes d'information très
dérogatoires qui ont été mises en oeuvre
pendant la crise sanitaire
soit
banalisée et on récuse qu'on appelle un
peu dans notre jargon aussi le
solutionnisme technologique donc vous
rejoins tout à fait de ce point de vue
là merci beaucoup merci Monsieur Gilles
Legendre
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente vous ne m'en voudrez pas le
la question ne porte pas strictement sur
la question du covid mais un certain
nombre de réponses que vous avez
apportées ou d'éléments qui figurait
dans vos réponses m'encouragent à
m'éloigner un tout petit peu de ce sujet
lors des échanges notamment avec mon
collègue réberoth vous avez souligné le
fait que les moyens avaient assez
sensiblement augmenter à l'occasion des
tailles du texte sur la rgpd et j'ai cru
comprendre que vous aviez notamment
améliorer renforcer assez fortement les
capacités de la CNIL notamment en
matière de conformité pour mieux aider
les professionnels de toute nature à
s'adapter à ces nouvelles règles dont
tout le monde connaît la complexité
alors cette démarche me semble
intéressante en elle-même j'aurais aimé
que vous nous décriviez un petit peu
plus précisément en quoi elle consiste
vous avez fait allusion dans une autre
réponse à une autre question au fait que
les contrôles voir parfois les erreurs
vous donnez l'occasion d'accompagner
mais est-ce qu'il y a aussi un
investissement en amont un travail
pédagogique notamment vis-à-vis des
petites ou des moyennes entreprises pour
lequel l'application des règles est
souvent un casse-tête parce qu'ils n'ont
pas les équipements humains ou et
parfois les moyens économiques qui leur
permettent de le faire évidemment
c'est aussi peut-être instructif pour
d'autres autorités similaires ou
cousines de la vôtre on est dans un
contexte vous l'avez souligné et c'est
pas terminé
d'explosion des normes des règles vous
avez fait mention des règles qui
allaient venir des nouvelles
réglementations européennes qu'est-ce
qu'on peut tirer au stade actuel de
votre expérience dans ce domaine qui
permettrait d'être mutualisé à d'autres
autorités
je vous remercie madame Julie le
chanteur
merci Monsieur président bonjour madame
la Présidente mes chers collègues un
récent décret a permis la prolongation
de l'application tous anti-covid
jusqu'au 31 janvier 2023 alors que la
CNIL Commission Nationale Informatique
et Liberté dont vous êtes la présidente
avait demandé la publication d'un
rapport sur le fonctionnement de
l'application tous anti covid pour
janvier 2021 ce rapport n'a été publié
qu'un an après la date fixée d'une part
et n'a fait l'objet d'absolument aucune
information publique d'autre part une
fois que l'on a trouvé ce rapport perdu
dans les tréfonds du site de tous
anticovid on y lit plusieurs
informations très intéressantes nous
démontrons notamment que le dispositif
n'a absolument pas eu l'efficacité
espérée en effet le rapport précis que
l'efficacité technique de tout anticoïde
a été sous optimale dans le nombre de
personnes testées positives à la covid
qui ne se sont pas déclarés à
l'application était élevée de plus la
fonction de suivi des utilisateurs sont
ses pouvoirs retracer des chaînes de
contamination pour stopper la
propagation du virus a été évidemment
sous-utilisé amenant l'application un
être utile que pour stocker le Pass
sanitaire de plus l'application a montré
ses faiblesses à plusieurs reprises
notamment concernant la protection des
données personnelles puisque l'anonymat
des utilisateurs n'était en aucun cas
assuré pour rappel la création de ce
dispositif qui use des données
personnelles des millions d'utilisateurs
étaient conditionnés à ce que ce rapport
d'impact soit publié ce qui n'a pas été
le cas et qu'il démonte cette réelle
utilité pardon manifestement ça n'a pas
fonctionné je souhaiterais également le
souligner qu'en plus de l’inification
avérée du dispositif celui-ci a coûté un
argent incroyable aux français puisque
c'est 7 millions d'euros que cela a
coûté à nos concitoyens
donc de questions madame la Présidente
vous savez nous sommes attachés aux
libertés des Français donc
qu'attendez-vous pour vous prononcer en
faveur de l'arrêt de cette application
et enfin qu'adviendra-t-il des données
personnelles de ces millions de Français
notamment leur traçage collectés depuis
le début de la pandémie je vous remercie
madame la Présidente
merci madame la Présidente pour votre
exposé et vos réponses très claires et
qui j'avoue aurait été utile très utile
avant nos travaux de cet été sur la loi
de prolongation des systèmes
d'information SIDEP et contact covid
alors évidemment c'est pas de votre
faute si vous n'avez pas pu être entendu
à cet été parce que le gouvernement
c'est lui qui a décidé en urgence cet
été de nous faire prolonger ces systèmes
d'information et à l'époque je dois dire
que la pression était très forte sur
nous les sur les responsables politiques
que nous sommes pour la prolongation de
ces systèmes d'information l'argument
était en fait de on nous a transmis du
point de vue du gouvernement une sorte
de d'angoisse de l'écrasement de ces
fichiers vous imaginez c'est un nouveau
variant et qu'il est terrible et quand
on a plus idée on a plus contact covid
qu'est-ce qui va se passer il y avait
une sorte d'angoisse qui nous était
transmise en disant personne ne vous
pardonnera vous les députés d'avoir
laissé écraser ces fichiers si important
dans la maîtrise éventuelle d'une d'une
pandémie et quand je vous entends
aujourd'hui et c'est très clair de vos
propos il y a clairement une tension il
faut la dire entre le concept de
pérennisation et le concept de
limitation dans le temps il y a deux
choses là qui sont contradiction
clairement on a des on a des collègues
qui pensent aujourd'hui que contenus de
l'évolution climatique les zones etc les
risques de pandémie qui sont réels on ne
peut plus se passer de ce genre de
choses il faut les pérenniser et à
l'inverse que vous semblez dire enfin
vous ce que vous dites très clairement
moi ce que j'entends dans ce que vous
dites c'est que il faut assumer que la
caducité enfin la péremption des
fichiers car ils ont un tas de début
date de fin et que quand c'est fini on
arrête on arrête on écrase le fichier
quitte le cas échéant en rouvrira si
besoin dans le cas de SIDEP et contact
covid je pense qu'il faut quand même
reconnaître que un les gens se sont
eux-mêmes sortis du système on ne
faisant pas un dépistage en donnant pas
les noms de leurs contacts donc de toute
façon
efficacité était érodée et enfin mais ça
a été dit par ma collègue Elsa faucillon
j'aimerais que vous rappeliez à nos
collègues que le meilleur le fichier le
mieux protégé c'est celui qui n'existe
pas
merci madame Cécile dermeyer merci
monsieur le Président merci madame la
Présidente pour vous propose je pense
que la clarté et puis l'avancée que vous
nous donnez l'éclairage que vous nous
faites après finalement cette période
extrêmement compliquée de crise que nous
avons vécu est extrêmement utile et
effectivement les propos sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes les orientations sont
plus assurées plus affirmés et c'est
normal moi ce que je voulais vous dire
c'est déjà vous remercier parce que ce
travail colossal qui a été mené ici au
gouvernement aussi il faut le dire et
avec une autorité administrative
indépendante telle que la vôtre a
démontré finalement qu'on avait une
organisation en capacité d'essayer de
porter bien sûr ces sujets majeurs qui
sont la protection de la vie privée
devant une crise majeure sanitaire à
laquelle il fallait répondre je crois
que vous vous avez dit on n'a pas de
raison de pas vous croire que la
relation avec le gouvernement dans le
cadre de cette crise c'est relativement
bien passé que vous n'avez pas souffert
d'obstacle en tout cas je souhaiterais
que vous puissiez nous le confirmer
et que finalement cette cette page il
faut un moment la tournée pour en ouvrir
une autre si besoin en tout cas il faut
vraiment la fermer et sur ce point je
pense qu'on est d'accord et on sera
vigilant sur que sur le fait que cette
page se ferme et se ferme bien pour que
les données soient bien protégées et ça
j'en viens donc à ma première question
comment allez-vous organiser
c'est d'abord comment réaliser vous ces
contrôles vous l'avez dit avec un
juriste et un ingénieur est-ce que
écartons l'idée que vous vous avez un
recours au cabinet de conseils j'imagine
que ça n'est pas le cas vous n'avez pas
de consultant externe c'est un élément
important et je voulais vous demander
également la période de 10 ans me paraît
très longue est-ce que vous avez
maintenant une philosophie sur cette
question de la conservation des données
pendant les 10 ans et enfin est-ce que
ça vous a fait évoluer vous
personnellement sur la notion du secret
médical par rapport au 21e siècle et par
rapport aux problèmes que nous
rencontrons actuellement madame Clara
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente déjà je vous remercie pour
les propos que vous avez pu nous
exprimer qui sont à la fois utiles et
rassurants je vais me permettre de
d'élargir un peu la thématique de
l'audition parce que j'ai récemment eu
des échanges en circonscription qui
m'ont alerté sur l'opportunité
d'améliorer le traitement des données de
personnes interpellées par la police
afin de faciliter leur identification
aujourd'hui une personne qui est placée
en garde à vue peut avoir été enregistré
plusieurs fois dans le fichier des
traitements des antécédents judiciaires
sous une fausse identité ce qui rend
impossible la capacité des forces de
l'ordre à connaître ces antécédents
parce qu'ils sont pas interconnectés
avec les fichiers automatisés
d'empreinte digitales et le fichier
automatisé des empreintes génétiques en
2016 un rapport de la Cour des comptes
proposé de connecter ces deux fichiers
avec une base commune pour améliorer la
fiabilité des identités et repérer plus
systématiquement les individus
signalisés dans ces bases qui sont des
individus qui ont qui ont pu commettre
des crimes graves dans le même esprit
nos collègues did Paris c'est Pierre
Morel à l'huissier ont proposé dans un
rapport en 2018 qui était
particulièrement intéressant de mettre
en relation les trois fichiers sous la
forme d'une base pivot pour qu'en
consultant l'une des bases il soit
possible d'avoir accès aux informations
qui qui seraient contenu dans les deux
autres même si il existe donc des freins
juridiques aujourd'hui et que l'exigence
de protection des données des directives
européennes sont évidemment des
garde-fous fondamentaux pour autant
malgré les réticences politiques qui
sont parfois invoqués certains
croisements sont déjà opérés dans le
système d'information Schengen par
exemple
ainsi madame la Présidente je voulais
s'en remettre en cause donc c'est cette
protection des données personnelles et
au regard de l'utilité que
représenterait une meilleure
identification des personnes mises en
cause ce qui vous paraîtrait
envisageable que l'on puisse avancer sur
ce sujet avec éventuellement la
possibilité de créer cette base pivot et
dans le cas contraire qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui s'y opposerait je te
remercie merci Madame Elisa Martin
bonjour merci beaucoup de votre venue et
de vos propos
moi ma question accompagne d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de préoccupations qui ont
été soulevés jusqu'à maintenant il y a
donc le développement d'un certain
nombre de nouvelles technologies de
nouveaux outils d'une manière générale
d'ailleurs dans l'opmi le recours assez
nouveaux outils ces nouvelles
technologies paraît occupées une place
très importante mais peu importe je
ferme cette parenthèse est-ce que vous à
la CNIL vous avez les moyens que je
qualifierais de technique pour évaluer
les capacités de ces nouveaux outils à
être faiblement protégé
à être utilisé dans d'autres contextes
et pour d'autres pour d'autres
utilisations est-ce que vous avez une
capacité de cette nature ou est-ce que
vous pouvez la solliciter qui n'existe
pas à l'intérieur de la CNIL pour se
donner un certain nombre de garanties
autour encore une fois de de tous ces
nouveaux outils qui qui arrivent
merci et enfin Monsieur Jean
merci monsieur le Président Madame
présidente mais mes propos vont
s'inscrire dans dans la lignée une fois
n'est pas coutume de de se présenter par
ma collègue Cécile
tout d'abord vous dire que la
représentation nationale vous remercie
sincèrement du retour de la CNIL sur
l'efficacité la pertinence des systèmes
d'information et traitement de données
que nous avons mis en place pendant la
crise sanitaire je tiens ici à le
rappeler et nous étions nombreux déjà
commissaires aux lois lors des
différentes auditions que nous avions pu
mener s'agissant de la mise en place de
ces systèmes d'information d'avoir
quelques doutes sur la pertinence de
leur mise en place dans l'efficacité
n'était pas avérée pour lutter contre la
crise sanitaire étant peut-être aussi
également les problématiques en termes
de liberté publique pouvait se poser et
je crois que vos avis la vie de l'acnil
de l'autorité indépendante que vous
représentez ont été importants dans les
choix du législateur de se prononcer sur
la mise en place de ce type de
dispositif
notamment vous l'avez rappelé dans les
conditions d'urgence que que sont celles
que nous avons vécues dans le cadre de
cette de cette crise sanitaire je
voulais ici vous poser une une question
sur la mise en place de tout son petit
covid contrairement à ce que j'ai pu
entendre du côté du rassemblement
national vous avez dans vos propos
introductifs très clairement indiqué que
cette application était respectueuse de
la vie privée nonobstant le traçage mis
en place qui n'est pas de risque majeur
pour les libertés publiques vous l'avez
aussi également indiqué et qu'il était
conforme au rgpd en revanche j'ai pas su
bien pris voir dans votre dans votre
propos qui a suivi quand on a parlé de
l'utilité de ce dispositif vous avez
évoqué peut-être les difficultés
d'appréciation de cette utilité selon
qu'on était avant l'existence d'une
crise sanitaire ou si c'était pendant
que ce dispositif était le plus utile et
ne pas avoir les éléments pour vous
permettre de l'évaluer j'aurais voulu
avoir peut-être un peu plus
d'explications à ce sujet merci
merci madame la Présidente pour répondre
à ces questions
merci monsieur le Président et je me
réjouis beaucoup en tout cas encore
beaucoup de questions sur ces sujets
qui nous sont chers à l'acné qu'on
considère évidemment comme important
alors monsieur Gilles Legendre posait
en tout cas une question sur l'émission
d'accompagnement de la CNIL donc dans le
cadre de la crise sanitaire je les ai
évoquées 31 avirandus très audition
parlementaire avec celle-ci voilà donc
ce cas sur l'aspectrice sanitaire je n'y
reviens pas d'une façon plus générale
nous faisons vraiment autant
d'accompagnement que
d'action répressives traitement des
plaintes contrôle et
mesure
répressives sanction mise en demeure ou
autre parce qu'on est convaincu que la
pédagogie est vraiment
indispensable sur ces sujets y compris
auprès des plus jeunes d'ailleurs nous
faisons beaucoup d'éducation au
numérique avec le prisme de la
protection des données on
associations fondations d'entreprise etc
on va publier des ressources par exemple
pour les 8 10 ans enfin d'ici quelques
jours d'un partenariat avec l'Éducation
nationale on est très actif sur ce sujet
plus globalement sur l'ensemble de
l'accompagnement on fait beaucoup de
droits souples d'abord on est à l'écoute
on est je pense une des rares deai à
répondre au téléphone on a vraiment des
permanences téléphoniques les membres du
collège collective ont pu visiter
notamment et parfois certains députés
parce qu'on a fait des visites si ça
vous intéresse c'est très instructif de
voir quelles sont les questions que se
posent nos concitoyens et nous ça nous
aide beaucoup à pas être un régulateur
hors-sol et puis on espère pouvoir
vraiment répondre
utilement à des questions il y a la
possibilité aussi par un dispositif qui
s'appelle besoin d'aide de poser des
questions par voie électronique par mail
et auxquels on essaye également de
répondre on a un service
qui est spécialisé avec plus d'une
dizaine de personnes dans
l'accompagnement à la délégués à la
protection des données parce qu'il y a
maintenant 30
000 en France
on met des outils à disposition par
exemple on a créé un MOOC il y a 3 ans
qui sont enrichis progressivement de
différents modules un depuis quelques
mois par exemple à destination des
collectivités locales avec une quinzaine
de fiches l'état civil le périscolaire
etc
ce MOOC il a déjà fait l'objet de 140
000 créations de comptes c'est pour vous
dire qu'il y a un appétit parce que faut
avoir envie de se mettre devant un écran
pendant trois ou quatre heures on essaye
de le faire de façon la plus pédagogique
possible mais donc il y a vraiment un
besoin de pédagogie et j'espère surtout
que nos concitoyens et peut-être le
milieu entrepreneurial qui a vu arriver
le rgpd avec une certaine réticence
parce qu'on peut comprendre que c'est
une réglementation supplémentaire
complexe à mettre en œuvre etc
on voit tout l'intérêt parce que je
crois qu'il y aura pas de développement
durable serein de l'économie numérique
sont cette confiance que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure et je crois que les Yaris de
réputation et et à l'inverse un avantage
concurrentiel distinctif pour un certain
nombre d'entreprises à protéger les
données de leur concitoyens donc comme
je l'ai évoqué on fait beaucoup
d'accompagnement à travers des têtes de
réseau parce que c'est pas avec 290
agents qu'on peut faire de
l'accompagnement très individualisé sauf
pour des très gros acteurs ou parce que
étant cause une technologie qui peut
avoir des des effets importants on fait
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle le droit
souple c'est à dire de référentiel on
parlait qu'on a parlé de santé quasiment
une grande partie de la matinée on a
publié un référentiel pour les cabinets
médicaux et paramédicaux concrètement
vous êtes médecin dans un cabinet
médical qu'est-ce que vous devez faire
comment vous devez informer vos passions
sur l'utilisation des de ces données
quels sont les mesures de sécurité que
vous devez prendre on a fait la même
chose en publiant un référentiel pour
les officines de pharmacie on a un site
qui est une mine d'or je dis pas que
c'est facile nécessairement de naviguer
dessus mais on a quand même eu 11
millions de connexions à notre site
l'année dernière c'est d'autant que le
site du ministère de la justice etc ce
qui prouve qu'il y a un besoin de
contenu auquel on essaye de répondre
vous avez évoqué les PME TPE on a publié
un guide en lien avec BPI France
précisément
parce qu'on a conscience que les
exigences qu'on peut avoir à l'égard
d'une toute petite entreprise sont pas
les mêmes que celles qu'on peut avoir à
l'égard d'un groupe du CAC 40 pour
essayer de simplifier au maximum les
problématiques pour les startups on va
station F notamment pour les évangéliser
entre guillemets sur la protection des
données donc vraiment c'est un
accompagnement multiforme pour
lesquelles il y a une orientation en
tout cas j'ai dit d'avoir une
orientation qui soit plus qui se
projette en de Paris on va faire
vraiment le tour des régions on a
commencé à Lyon
il y a peu de temps où on était réuni
avec la plus grande association de
déléguer la protection des données
300 personnes dans la salle il y avait
eu 500 demandes pour
évoquer les principes du rgpd
j'ai lancé depuis l'année dernière un
bac à sable qui alors c'est pas un bac à
sable pour s'affranchir de la
réglementation ou pour jouer tout
simplement mais c'est un bac à sable par
lequel suite à un appel à projet on
accompagne pendant quelques mois tous
les ans sur une thématique particulière
une dizaine d'acteurs et on essaye d'en
tirer des enseignements plus généraux
qu'on fait connaître c'était Hélène Gimi
aubreo s'en souvient l'année dernière
sur la santé numérique justement
pour que les projets innovants soient
accompagnés dès le départ et cette année
c'est sur les aid tech aide comme
éducation vraiment le numérique dans
l'éducation et d'ailleurs ce thème du
numérique dans l'éducation nous ferons
un colloque sur ce sujet début
novembre
donc voilà ce que je peux dire
globalement sur l'accompagnement on n'a
pas la prétention de servir de modèle à
qui que ce soit mais c'est vraiment une
de nos
[Musique]
fondamentaux de notre ADN et on essaye
en permanence de de s'adapter et de
répondre
au plus près du terrain au
préoccupations qui sont posées
par ailleurs donc Madame le chanteur
évoquait le rapport sur tous anti covid
alors quid des données de tout son petit
covid et bien donc elle ne sont
conservées que pendant enfin que entre
guillemets
un certain temps mais elles n'ont été
conservées ou elle ne doivent être
conservées que pendant une quinzaine de
jours
donc les données de l'historique de
proximité c'est 15 jours à compter de
leur enregistrement par l'application du
téléphone et les données de l'historique
de proximité des contacts à risque qui
sont partagés sur le serveur central
c'est 15 jours aussi à compter de leur
enregistrement et donc comme vous le
savez l'application sera désactivée
le 31 janvier
prochain
et encore une fois c'est une application
sur quelle la CNIL a obtenu
en lien avec les
personnes qui se sont occupées de leurs
conception des garanties dès le début en
matière de vie privée dès le début de
sa mise en oeuvre mais j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'en parler sur l'utilité
marginale de la fonction traçage en tout
cas de cette application pour la
résolution de la crise
Raquel Garrido
évoquait
l'angoisse de l'écrasement des fichiers
n'ont pas la sienne j'ai l'impression
mais en tout cas c'est le qui pouvait
être lié le cas échéant
ça pose effectivement toute la
problématique de la pérennisation de de
certains de ces dispositifs
moi je pense effectivement que comme le
collège de la CNIL que la plupart de ces
dispositifs
doivent avoir une date de péremption
doivent être désactivées sauf dans deux
cas notamment et pour certains
des données collectées à travers ces
dispositifs c'est en pour des raisons de
pharmacovigilance je pense notamment au
vaccin c'est quand même logique de
pouvoir le cas échéant dans quelques
années revenir vers tel ou telle
personne en cas de besoin et d'autre
part pour des besoins de recherche
mais dans des conditions qui font que
les données des personnes qui sont
utilisées
le soi dans des conditions de protection
de la vie privée qu'on a calibré en tout
cas qu'on a vérifié
nous-même
mais ça pose plus globalement en fait
sur l'évaluation de ces dispositifs je
pense que ce qui est nécessaire on a des
évaluations en silo en quelque sorte
système d'information par système
d'information nous paraît très important
dans l'éventualité d'une réflexion sur
la pérennisation de certains dispositifs
et autant que possible c'est
certainement compliqué mais qui est une
évaluation
qui soit plus globale des interactions
entre ces différents systèmes
d'information
notamment et
ça mais je vais revenir après sur
d'autres
interventions mais ça me permet d'une
certaine façon de répondre tout de suite
à Monsieur jeantal à propos de tac parce
que effectivement
peut-être que c'est
utile de d'évaluer tout antico vide au
regard de l'évaluation du système
d'information contact covid
quels sont les interactions entre l'un
et l'autre est-ce que les deux sont
utiles en même temps à quel moment de la
propagation du virus
l'utilisation tout sentie covid n'a pas
nécessairement la même utilité peut-être
plus une utilité d'identification de
pics de contamination si c'est au tout
début de l'utilisation de tous anti
covid plus une complémentarité que les
actions de d'enquête manuelles si c'est
au moment où le virus circule davantage
madame Cécile Luther
demander un peu comment fonctionnait les
contrôles en
l'espèce à l'édition de données de santé
particulièrement sensible nous nous
faisions et c'est juridiquement
nécessaire accompagné par un médecin
nous avons fait aussi très attention
dans toute cette période de contrôle et
nous continuons à le faire mais
évidemment au pic de la crise à ne pas
avoir des méthodes de contrôle qui
n'empêchaient pas les équipes de
travailler
les enfin je parle pas des équipes de la
CNIL mais en tout cas qui ne
perturbaient pas en tout cas les
organismes qu'on allait contrôler
on a vraiment fait des contrôles très en
temps réel on a obtenu des modifications
sur un certain nombre de sujets vraiment
en temps réel des zones de commentaires
libres des choses comme ça qui n'avaient
pas lieu d'être des questions de
sécurité
et par un dial continue avec les
responsables de traitement à ma
connaissance nous ne faisons pas appel à
des cabinets de conseil voilà je crois
pas que nous en aurions les moyens
d'assurant tout état de cause
et le secret médical c'est vraiment
effectivement
une notion absolument fondamentale à
avoir en tête dans le cadre de la mise
en oeuvre de système d'information tels
que ceux qui ont été mis en oeuvre et
c'est bien parce que c'est fondamental
que c'est le législateur qui doit en
délimiter en quelque sorte les contours
et les exceptions quand il y a des
exceptions de façon très
rigoureuse
madame Chassagneux posait des questions
sur le traitement des antécédents
judiciaires
j'ai certainement une question légitime
en elle-même qui a un lien assez tenu
avec l'objet
de l'audition de ce matin donc nous
reviendrons vers vous sur ce sujet ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que la CNIL
est très attentive
sur les modalités de mise en oeuvre des
fichiers régaliens d'une façon générale
on contrôle régulièrement les fichiers
mis en oeuvre par le ministère de
l'intérieur ou par le ministère de la
Défense par exemple et d'ailleurs le FAD
par exemple le fichier des empreintes
génétiques a fait l'objet d'une sanction
de la CNIL il y a un an un rappel à
l'ordre public une injonction de mise en
conformité notamment sur les durées de
conservation qui
en tout cas
demande de mise en conformité qui a été
adressée au ministère de l'Intérieur
alors madame Elisa Martin posait les
questions posées la question des moyens
que nous avions pour évaluer les
nouveaux outils qui peuvent être mis en
oeuvre alors on a beaucoup de chance à
la CNIL parce que par rapport à d'autres
autorités de protection des données je
pense qu'on est la seule autorité de
protection des données au sein de
l'Union européenne avoir un laboratoire
d'innovation numérique qui s'appelle le
Link avec des chercheurs d'ailleurs avec
une recherche de multi une approche
multidisciplinaire des ingénieurs
naturellement mais aussi des sociologues
je veux aussi développer si c'est
possible un peu la fonction économique
de de la CNIL parce que la régulation de
la donnée il faut aussi comprendre les
enjeux de régulation économique de la
donnée à fortiori avec les nouveaux
textes européens qui arrivent sur le
partage et sur l'ouverture des données
ou sur l'intelligence artificielle donc
nous avons nos propres ressources même
si elles ne sont jamais suffisantes on
produit d'ailleurs des livres blancs là
on en a produit un par exemple sur les
sur les assistants vocaux en ouvrant le
capot des des assistants vocaux parce
que fois cette très révélateur de
caractéristiques très intime et
personnelle des personnes avec la voix
vous pouvez identifier évidemment
le genre l'âge de la personne sa
situation peut-être la peut-être la
fumée la clope comme vous dites tout à
fait possible en tout cas ça peut
certainement divulguer des informations
médicales même malgré soi on a fait un
livre blanc sur les moyens des données
de paiement par exemple sur les données
de paiement parce qu'on voit qu'on
s'achemine vers un monde
sans cache entre guillemets et donc qui
multiplie les possibilités de traçage de
nos comportements
financiers notamment et puis vous
parliez de pouvoir solliciter d'autres
expertises le gouvernement a mis en
place au ministère de l'Économie le
pérenne qui est un service
donc en tout cas de qui permet de faire
des études numériques et auxquelles un
certain nombre d'aïs d'autorités
administratives indépendantes dont nous
faisons partie peuvent avoir avoir accès
ou sollicités ou définir en commun des
études ce que nous faisons également
voilà monsieur le Président à ce stade
ce que je pouvais vous dire en espérant
de ne pas avoir été trop longue
c'était très complet je vous remercie
pour cette audition venant des collègues
et puis de tous ceux qui ont assisté qui
ont qui ont pu bénéficier des
informations que vous avez donné merci
et à bientôt
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames et messieurs les députés merci
et peut-être à la semaine prochaine pour
certains d'entre vous